hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge mein
karfreitags ja immer so der minecraft
tages habe ich mir gedacht ich spiele
heute minecraft wir befinden uns hier
gerade im haus
das ist das home menü von minecraft ii
steht der name hier sind den ganzen
spielmodi ich weiß aber nicht was ich
jetzt zocken soll deswegen connecten
einfach mal auf dem komma hd punkte
server und schauen einfach mal was für
dann hier zocken können aber ihr habt
ihr schon artikel gelesen und zwar
möchte ich mit euch über ein paar dinge
reden die ein bisschen ernster sind ich
dafür jetzt einfach mal eine runde rage
mode weil der modus ist zwar sehr
ausraster last ich das ding ist aber
dass das hier relativ schnell geht man
muss nicht so sehr konzentrieren und
sagt einfach unten also auf mich bezogen
sterbe ich dann halt wieder sehr schnell
und dann bin ich wieder live und dann
sterbe ich wieder falls jetzt erwartet
dass ich euch den modus erklären ein
ich weiß selber nicht ganz genau wieder
funktioniert aber es geht doch nur darum
dass ich eigentlich über fünf themen mit
euch reden wollte das erste thema ist
bezogen auf übermorgen und zwar
übermorgen sonntag der zwanzigste märz
und ich hatte relativ genau vor einem
monat angeboten die vor
ich hatte am 21 februar geburtstag und
hat mir halt gedacht oh ja ich habe
eigentlich gar nicht richtig irgendwie
euch ein geburtstagsgeschenk gegeben
meinerseits an euch und ihr habt mir so
viele sachen gemacht wir wurden bilder
von kuchen zugesendet von ganz vielen
schulklassen die murger annan und gesagt
haben herr alles gute ist ultra nice und
dafür wollte ich mich bedanken deswegen
hab ich mir gedacht da sich alle
technisch 20m luca shop und übermorgen
wenn ihr über morgen also am sonntag von
0 uhr morgens bis 0 uhr abends was im
lukas shop bestellt könnte als gutschein
code einfach luca 20 verbänden also luca
ich bin total luca 20 so könnt ihr euch
das einfach als unscheinbar einschreiben
oder kriegt ihr 20 auf jeden artikel und
das ist bei fünf euro liegen
acht euro die ihr dann das ist sache
nummer eins sachen nummer zwei geht auch
recht schnell und zwar bin ich bei
instagram instagram dot com / laser luca
hat sich da könnt ihr mir gerne folgen
ich bin allen and holt ich habe ihn
vorher glaub ich irgendwie 200 leuten
denn volk da waren sehr viele youtuber
freunde von mir dabei da waren sehr
viele reale freunde von mir dabei und da
war auch mein gott fucking passat ein
boden und kill und faktisch sei war ein
paar seiten dabei die einfach schöne
natur bilder gepostet haben andere
youtuber die ich kenne aus amerika und
england die ich sehr geil finden und wo
ich einfach wissen will was sie dann
machen unsere chips schon wieder cremig
hat in letzter zeit schon krass
abgefuckt als ich beispielsweise einfach
bilder von beispielsweise nach freundin
gelegt habe und dann kommen da leute
darunter anschreibens wo bist du die
freundin von kontraste bist du dies das
blabla ich meine natürlich muss ich
damit rechnen wenn ich meine zahl an
profil öffentlich teile dass da leute
das kommentieren und mir folgen und was
alles machen aber da ist ja verhindern
kann tue ich das jetzt ich weiß dass
leute immer noch sehen wenn ich bilder
leichter allerdings dadurch dass ich zu
vielen leuten nicht folglich nicht mehr
so viele bilder wenn ihr versteht was
ich meine außerdem habe ich ab und an
dann immer mehr fanpages von mir
abonniert wie beispielsweise ganz viele
luca shop fanpages oder coulibaly so was
alles und ich bin jetzt auch eigentlich
überhaupt nicht der typ der sich als
mensch darstellen würde mit zu vielen
tabs und so vielen leuten die sich
support und so vielen fans und alles ihr
seid meine kollegen und deswegen mag ich
kenne ist allgemein nicht so gerne aber
da ich immer mehr fanpages gefolgt bin
und auch immer mehr die bilder gelegt
habe habe ich das gefühl bekommen das
ist auch immer mehr fan girls gab und
immer mehr nachrichten habe ich bekommen
vom wegen luca bitte schreib mir das
wenn mein größter traum und das ist mir
so dass haben babys beauty palace und da
gebe aber ich hab doch nicht so ein
scheiß man will dann solchen fanpages
auch nicht immer and folgen weil das der
dann teilweise ihren tag dann aus der
stellen kann wenn die sagen nein
ein held folgt mir nicht mehr also fuhr
ich das halt überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen kann das sollte nicht
gegen die fanpage betreiber gehen auch
nicht gegen youtuber gehen aber einfach
ich habe gesagt ja jetzt nimmt mir
wirklich so viel zeit weg weil ich immer
instagram rein gehe und sehe wo der und
er hat etwas hochgeladen dann wieder was
anschauen das mir fehlt sehr viel zeit
in meinem tag und das ist ein bisschen
das ist der primäre grund warum ich alle
nennt folgten dritte sache geht auch
recht schnell und zwar habe ich die
blogs angekündigt mal auf twitter und
den dahinter dich jetzt zum hit ich habe
daily blogs angekündigt mal auf twitter
mal auch in videos ich habe mir sogar
schon in krippe und gekauft wird
allerdings in naher zukunft erst mal
nicht kommen weil ich einfach
unglaublichen stress habe oh mein gott
dem skill ich mache derzeit ein
praktikum ich studiere derzeit ich
schreibe eine arbeit über das praktikum
ich mache youtube nebenbei ich fliege
sehr oft nach berlin ich mache bald noch
so viele sachen die ich noch gar nicht
verraten darf ich schlafe derzeit pro
nacht drei bis vier stunden ich bis
dahin ich bin komplett müde den ganzen
tag über meinen kopf erhält der krieg
der so blöd mittlerweile weil ich
einfach mein ganzes leben für mein leben
derzeit opfere deswegen day die blogs
ich stelle also ein bisschen schlaf über
youtube und gesundheit über youtube und
deswegen ich habe übels bock drauf kommt
bald vielleicht vierte sache hängt damit
zusammen und zwar bin ich vom 25 märz
bis zum 31 märz also warte moment hey
ich bin vom 25 märz bis 31 märz in new
york
da werden keine die blogs kommen um also
aufs thema zurückzukommen weil ich nicht
mit mir die reise dadurch zerstören will
dass ich da mit einer kamera darum love
what the [ __ ] ich glaube dass ich die
stadt nicht so wie ich glaube ich würden
die reise dadurch zerstören wenn ich
alles irgendwie filmen wollen würde
natürlich hätte ich dann im nachhinein
so was wo ich sage okay das sind das
habe ich an dem und umfassen das habe
ich an dem tag erlebt aber ich möchte
dann lieber den moment genießen und
nicht so
barroso ich produziere für die zeit
videos vor
und es kommen keine blogs von new york
aber ich weiß nicht ob ihr das wollt
aber vielleicht nachdem ich von new york
zurück wenn an einem 30 vielleicht eine
woche später irgendwann anfang april
alle sachen die ich vielleicht gefilmt
habe zusammen steigen zum blog wollt ihr
dass das wetter so eine art abschluss
läuft also gibt einfach mal ein like bei
dem video oder so und dann gucke ich ob
ich das mache jetzt kommen wir zum
fünften sache die mich am meisten
beschäftigt und zwar die entwicklung von
youtube deutschland hat es tatsächlich
ein thema das ich schon sehr lange reden
möchte wenn man mir auf snap chat folgt
oder auf twitter oder auf sonstigen
plattformen ich äußere mich immer total
kritik reicht über die deutsche
community und nicht fakt eigentlich
alles ab das ist die kurzfassung dazu
muss ich allerdings erst mal sagen dass
ich selber kein perfektes beispiel für
einen perfekten youtuber bin ich
betreibe selber leichtes klick dating
und hast du [ __ ] ich betreibe selber
leichtes klick belting ich habe meine
titel komplett in tabs das liegt
allerdings daran weil ich besser finden
wenn etwas auf einer gleichen höhe ist
dass ich bin einfach perfektionistisch
geprägt das ist aber ein anderes thema
jedenfalls bin ich selber kein perfektes
beispiel aber viele sachen stören mich
und es gibt wie soll ich das sagen ich
bin wie so ein regionalliga fußball club
ich bin nicht perfekt also ich 40 in der
ersten liga aber ich bin noch nicht
komplett scheiße und spiele in der
kreisliga ist meiner meinung nach
entwickeln sich youtube deutschland in
letzter zeit komplett beschlüssen des
immer du bist du und ich finde das ist
nicht durch die zuschauer entstand oder
durch die community oder durch
irgendwelche anderen externen einflüsse
oder umweltfaktoren whatever sondern
durch die youtuber selbst ich rede da
von sachen wie beispielsweise gefakten
titeln wurden beispielsweise drinsteht
sie zeigten ihre titten oder schwuler
mann will mich [ __ ] oder irgendwas
anderes sonntag dann auch noch durch
unzählige rote pfeile
und kreise auf fem nails und riesige
text von paradebeispiel für so einen
komplett behindertes beispiel wer
einfach von bild wo titten drauf sind
und also eine rote von tippten
ausrufezeichen an so ein typ der so
guckt und dann in den titel noch the
rakes ex porno +18 ich meinen wie am
anfang schon gesagt ich bin selber kein
perfektes beispiel ich habe selber da
haben es ruhig so gucke oder wo ich in
titel schreibt +18 wo ich vor augen
spieler spiele
allerdings gibt es da leute die so über
die stränge schlagen sorry ich werde
dabei leicht aggressiv weil mich diese
ganzen leute so abpacken es gibt streit
die wahrscheinlich inszeniert waren nur
um die reichweite zu steigern wenn du
hast beispielsweise und es gibt halt
einfach auch komplett hirnverbrannte
menschen beispielsweise mehr getan was
sollte seine aktion davon ein paar tagen
und wenn ich dann halt so videos sehen
wie beispielsweise getränk an meinen
vater oder erste von youtube an erraten
oder jemand läuft in lw und belästigt
irgendwelche menschen und fragt sie nach
drogen und endet am ende dessen fucking
frank was ist mit euch spaß dies muss um
mein gott ich werde so aggressiv wenn
ich an solchen
ich glaube mein netzwerk mein manager
jeder wird mich für dieses video hassen
es ich muss es loswerden habt ihr
irgendeine form von anstand meine fresse
ich meine natürlich habe ich vom netz wo
ich ein bisschen behindert gucken und
natürlich habe ich videos gemacht wo
frauen vielleicht ab und zu freizügig
angezogen waren allerdings habe ich
nicht so über die stränge geschlagen wie
es einige menschen machen so viele
verdammte youtuber in deutschland
stellen klicks und geld und aufrufe und
abonnenten und wachstum und fucking
scheiß zahlen wie bei moralische werte
und menschenrechte teilweise schon und
methan sagt seinem vater er sei schwul
sein vater schlägt ihn was einfach nur
heiß dass in seiner familie häuslicher
gewalt ist und dass die eltern nicht
wollen dass jemand schwul ist und das
ist ein kleinen grunde niemanden zu
schlagen märz tagt am ende des videos so
was in die richtung aber ich bin doch
nicht schwul so nach dem mord nach motto
jetzt ob ich so etwas machen würde als
wenzel straftat wäre schwul zu sein ich
selber bin nicht schwul aber ich weiß
dass wenn ich zu meinen eltern
würde und ihm sagen würde dass ich
homosexuell bin würde das video so
langweilig sein wie sonst was sie sagen
würden
ok akzeptieren wir mögen dich so wie du
bist aber so einen scheiß dann auch noch
online zu stellen ich meine viele sagen
ja er wusste ja nicht wie sein vater
dann reagiert er hat das video danach
aber geschnitten und hochgeladen und
dann schreibt er gelb rang in den titel
und hektar typ story freude dass ich
jetzt gerade ein bisschen auslastung ein
bisschen aggressiv werde aber solche
menschen will ich einfach kann dem nicht
das gleiche passieren wie sam pepper
dass er einfach seinen kanal dem
anschließen muss weil sie so viele leute
hassen oder das petition dagegen
gestartet werden ich weiß dass dein
netzwerk ihm schon gekündigt hat aber
ich finde sowas reicht nicht ich meine
solche leute die das ist doch meine
fresse wie schon tausend mal gesagt ich
hab selber keine 100 prozent weiße weste
ich denke das hat mittlerweile keinen
youtuber mehr weil man ja irgendwie
diesen trend mit gehen muss es hier
mittlerweile so entwickelt dass alle
angefangen haben mit click dating und
roten pfeilen teilweise und caps titeln
und alles und man muss irgendwie mit sie
über die eigenen videos mit den eigenen
titeln wenn man es so fortgesetzt hätte
einfach untergegangen werden derzeit box
wenn dann leute das ansehen tippt
natürlich etwas an was sind totale
eyecatcher ist mit roten kreise und samt
klick dating und caps lock und allem man
muss halt mitgehen aber wenn solche
leute so einen schwachsinn machen und
auch allgemein diese ganze prank sachen
border gehen leute auf die straße um
arme menschen und belästigen menschen
und alles und sagen am ende ist es in
prey und damit ist es entschuldigt leute
dann auch noch diese chatroulette videos
alter ihr filmleute woran ihr nicht die
rechte habt und man da sind so viele
verwirrte menschen auf chatroulette die
einfach alleine sind und vielleicht
freunde suchen oder vielleicht auch
menschen die einfach dann dumme aktionen
machen und sich teilweise nackt zeigen
und so was alles stellt euch mal vor
jemand der sich dann nackt zeigt sieht
später das video auf youtube wie es
einer filmt und alle machen sich über
den lustig und es in die kommentare
der ist direkt depressiv machen sich
diese ganzen bescheuerten youtuber
eigentlich mal darüber gedanken was sie
da hochladen
meine herren gegen oracle habe ich
nichts weil da kann man hashtags machen
und danach
man quasi leute in einer gruppe mit dem
man dann quasi skype mehr oder weniger
um die wissen ja dass sie gefilmt werden
was ich ja dazu entscheiden mit einem
youtube video aufzunehmen aber wenn
einer einfach durch chatroulette durch
gold um beispielsweise nacktes und was
weiß ich was tut und dann sinken youtube
und das -hoch ich werde nicht mehr was
in den köpfen von diesen menschen los
mit solchen leuten will ich nichts in
einer kompletten youtube karriere zu tun
haben bestimmt haben auch einige
youtuber was gegen mich ein zu wenden
und sagen auch dass luca dass sie mit
dem nie was zu tun haben wollen weil er
das und das und das falsch macht aber
das ist aber jedem so keiner ist perfekt
aber solche sachen freunde ich will
einfach mal meine gedanken loswerden das
video geht wahrscheinlich gerade was
weiß ich wie lang und ich habe nicht so
viel geschnitten wie sonst auch aber ich
kann mich ganz echt nicht halten das
sind einfach meine gedanken die wollen
raus und leute es tut mir leid viele
menschen argumentieren dann immer damit
vom wegen lotto spielt spiele sind zwar
deinem computer und so einen scheiß und
urteilte über das was andere machen ich
sag's mal anders und zwar an die
youtuber die sonnenschein abziehen für
was wollt ihr in zehn jahren auf der
straße erkannt werden für das dass
jemand zu euch ankommt und sagt ja du
bist doch der der vor zehn jahren da
games gezockt hat und das
zusammengeschnitten hat dich zu treffen
oder für sowas wie oder was auch der der
da vor zehn jahren bilder von anderen
youtuber rinnen der angeschaut hat und
dann am arsch erkannt dass wer das paar
oder hey du bist doch der real sein
vater gesagt hat dass angeblich schwul
sei und das voll schlimm dargestellt und
der vater dich doch dann versucht zu
schlagen oder hey bist du nicht der dnl
voll zum affen gemacht hat und dazu
anderen leuten und zur autofahrer den
gelaufen bist und einfach nur
geschrieben dass das waren prank stellt
euch die frage einfach mal selbst ich
weiß ich bin selber kein perfekter
mensch was youtube angeht das habe ich
jetzt auch schon öfters gesagt ich bin
kritikfähig wenn ihr mir schreiben wollt
aber bitte das war einfach mal meine
meinung ich zwinge mich immer so etwas
nicht zu tun das war jetzt so eine art
info video oder meinungs- video ich
meine diese gedanken liegen mir auf dem
herzen seit einem jahr youtube
entwickelt sich komplett beschissen man
selber muss ein bisschen damit mitgehen
sage ich mal weil man welcher selber
mich durch diese durch diese caps noch
titel angepasst habe weil man sonst
einfach nicht mehr gesehen wird man wird
doch nicht mehr gesehen stellt euch
einfach mal von der echten welt hätte
jeder auf einmal eine lampe auf den kopf
und wird in der nacht gesehen
und einer sagt anja ich bin nicht so
einer und ich mache weiter meinen dinge
wird er dann nicht gesehen werden in der
nacht das war zwar ein komplettes
beispiel aber so in etwa meine ich das
mal das video geht bei mir in der raw
datei gerade 40 minuten ich werde jetzt
versuchen auf 15 minuten runter zu
schneiden
es waren einfach mal meine gedanken ich
bin nicht perfekt es war einfach viele
sachen und dieses video vermehrt hat das
einfach zum überschwappen gebracht
diesen topf de schon komplett voll war
aber ich hoffe man konnte mich irgendwie
verstehen ich bin gespannt auf eure
kommentare in der beschreibung den hunde
die nicht daran habe den krieg die
übermorgen 20 prozent günstiger mit dem
kot mutter 20 m lukas shop und dann
sehen wir uns irgendwann wieder morgen
wahrscheinlich wenn ich bessere laune